[Music]
all right let's go to savannah in dallas
what's up savannah
hi how are you um we're we're rocking
and rolling how's it going good good
thank you how's dallas is it a thousand
degrees already
yes summers are humid and hot you know
yes yeah well welcome to it so how we
doing how can i help
good um i just have a question i wanted
to know
how and when do i tell my 14 year old
little sister that
about 13 years ago her dad sexually
assaulted me oh
jeez man
do you feel comfortable sharing the
story
um yeah
about what happened
yes um i was i was about eight years old
um
we were sitting on the couch my entire
family my stepdad me my little sister
she was a newborn at this time
and my mom and we were all sleeping
except for him
and i woke up that's good that's good
that's good that's good that's good yeah
i woke up and um yeah that's it
i'm so sorry
thank you
man
like the like the
i'm sorry that makes my i have to take a
breath i'm i'm taking a breath you're
the strong one here i'm taking a breath
um
that
it has a i have a uh
instant response that i have to
exhale through sometimes on those
um thank you for sharing that um so
where's that dude now
um living his life
not too far away from me
um he and my sister they still have a
supervised relationship
um he's from what i can tell a good dad
to her
by journey and everything that she wants
you know
it's not a good dad but
such it is
um did your parents
how did your
how did it when you did you tell
walk me through posts what happens
afterwards
i didn't tell anyone for
about a year and after it happened and
when i did tell my mom
um she didn't believe me you know she
asked me the typical questions like what
were you wearing i was in like night
pants so she told me that he wouldn't
have done that if i was wearing pants
and
he wouldn't have done that with my mom
sitting on the couch sleeping right next
to us and she asked him and he said he
would never do anything
and so
it wasn't until
many years later
i couldn't stand being in the same house
as him anymore and i kind of forced my
mom's hand
and she got us out
man
so you have the initial trauma which is
wrong it's evil
scorched earth
and then you turn to the one remaining
adult in your life and say help
and she says what were you wearing
[Music]
so that's trauma on top of a trauma and
then you got to
go home
every day
to a tiger that had already
damn near killed you once and you got to
go home to that every day
right yeah that was the hardest part
listen hon all of this was the hardest
part
i don't want to take away your story
from you all of this was the hardest
part
your mama should have believed you
should have got you out of there
and
probably i mean this is unfair to say
my dream would for you would have been
that you would have had a relationship
with her that you would have felt safe
coming that next day that's not the 14
year old there's no fault there on the
14 year old that's an ecosystem issue
you know what i'm saying
yeah
and that tells me there was already
challenges in that home
um
when you say you forced her hand what
does that look like because she wouldn't
have just left she would had to have
known there's other issues going on
um
[Music]
i called her one day and i just told her
i couldn't take it anymore and if she
didn't
do something for me i would call the
police personally
and so she came home from work and
that's when we packed our stuff and
laughed and that means she had to have
known he's abusive and other stuff was
going on
if she really didn't believe you she
wouldn't have left
yeah i mean i i'm not sure if she
did or if she didn't want me taking
matters like in my own hands
she always said that she believes that i
believe it happened oh my gosh dude
that's the most dismissive
re-traumatizing thing
wow
is she still defending that dude huh
yes she talks to him nearly every day
i don't say this lightly and if you've
listened to this show for a long time
you know i don't say this lightly you
got to get away from your mom
and i know that feels like the only
lifeline you got left but i need you to
hear me say it's killing you
um me and my mom we have a pretty good
relationship i know that listen listen
that it didn't happen but it did
and as the great vander kulk says your
body's keeping the score every time
you're around her
every conversation every time you
pretend something's not happening every
time she
like like
diverts from
where um
where she was or who she's on phone with
when you called
i'm so sorry
so when it comes to
i bet you got a uh
you better not tell anyone have you got
that
yes um i was to never tell anybody and
especially not my sister
man
and so hey so you've heard me like
here's what i know
your mother knows
something's off something doesn't write
here
and the you better never tell anybody
is almost always a cornerstone of
i know and i can't do life outside of
this context
and it wouldn't surprise me if your
mom's got a story too like uh i got some
challenges too
um
wow gosh what a mess
so
there
i i here's the deal i will not hold
secrets for people i won't
if
somebody has if i'm i'll hold
confidentiality
if a friend of mine calls and says hey
my marriage is falling apart i need some
help
i will never tell that stuff i'll go to
the grave with those conversations
um
if someone said hey i got a secret i'm
not holding that for you it's not my job
or especially if someone says hey this
evil was done to you you better not tell
anybody nope it's not how i work
does that work i can do that because i
know the secret kills me
saves it saves the perpetrator and it
kills me
the secrets wreak havoc on you
physiologically heart attacks cancer
stroke
it kills you okay so i'm not into the
business of keeping mom's precious
little secrets
and we'll get to sister so why now
what about right now makes you want to
go tell her
um well i just had my first baby i have
a seven month old daughter and now that
i have her
things are much more real
now that i'm a mom myself i just
couldn't imagine being my own mom
right
so this stuff stops with you right
exactly you're gonna believe your
daughter right
yes
good for you
that she's staring down a forest fire of
trauma good for you
thank you um
man and okay so hey you said it
this whole thing feels a lot more real
that's your body saying hey we remember
this story
little girls get hurt
and then their worlds explode
and then their mom puts a lid on the
explosion and makes them drink that
exploded air and blames you for it
your body remembers this story and so
every time you hold that baby little
girl or especially every time mom holds
that little baby girl
or that little baby girl is in the
presence of somebody else to sit on a
couch your body will sound the alarms
loud right and they feel like anxiety
and they feel like your stomach drops
out from underneath you and you want to
withdraw or you want to just go claw
somebody's eyes out for for seemingly no
reason that's your body saying hey hey
hey we've done this before we've done
this before and this time we were bigger
and we got muscles this time
right
right
tell me why you want to tell your 14
year old sister
um well i wasn't sure if i was going to
ever tell her
and my partner is the one who has been
really pushing me to work through this
and
find what's right and how to do the
right thing
especially for my sister
my only problem is she has very severe
anxiety um she's been medicated for it
for many years now and she's only 14.
so i'm just scared that this will
like send her off the deep end i don't
know yeah
so the two the two
things i'm holding in tension right now
um and i'm just going to process this
out loud so anybody listening to this
this is how i process this stuff in real
time
because i'm getting this story in real
time i knew a little bit about what this
call was about
not this level
so
if you want to tell her just to tell her
don't
or if you think you can
tell her to finally get back at
don't
it won't you won't get the cathartic
moment that you think you're gonna get
okay and i know that's hard to hear
the the cathartic moment is the police
and let's be super honest with you it's
13 years ago
and that's going to be a hard case
unless he's got child pornography on his
computer or a
a line of young girls comes forward and
says yeah me too me too me too
be tough right
especially when your own mom
didn't jump the gun back in the day
something tells me that she knows
something but again that's another
conversation
um
here's the other side of that tension
there's a 14 year old girl in the home
of a known sexual predator
and that's the part i'm not okay with
right well i mean it's always supervised
which leads me to believe that my mom
does know something yes
yes
so
have you gone to talk to somebody
no okay
you have to
yeah i think so i'm telling you because
i love you and
i think you're doing heroic things right
now
and i need you to hear me
that on the other end of this there is
healing that can happen and your life is
going to look different
okay but going along as you're going
along
is a recipe for burning out and when you
get tired and you get exhausted of from
holding your
mom's fake
nonsense together and trying to protect
yourself from a woman who should have
believed you and she didn't
and also knowing that your little sister
goes to visit with a sexual predator
every couple of days even though it's
supervised
and and and and and
you got this little baby with this
little baby girl the greatest gift you
can give this little baby girl is a
healed mom
yeah absolutely okay
so
you need to tell the story
and if you run and
tell it to a 14 year old now it's not
it's a it's not going to help you and b
yes i think it's going to be tough on
her so generally speaking if i'm going
to go have a conversation like that with
a 14 year old girl i'm going to bring a
professional in
i'm gonna call the school counselor and
i'm gonna have one or two or three
same gendered per people in their life
that are adults not kids
that can be a resource for them when
their world falls apart which it will
and when it does that is not the
person's that's not your fault
the person's fault it is is the sexual
perpetrator that hurts kids
it's the mother who didn't believe her
daughter
that's the villain in the story not you
for telling the truth
not you for saying i'm not keeping these
secrets
okay
every bit of the story will come back to
that you blew things up
you did that's what i'm scared of hey
listen it's a hundred percent coming and
that's what i'm telling you you need to
get away from your mom
you think you've made peace so you hear
here's the deal we talk about fight or
flight you've heard that before
yes okay
and there's fight flight and freeze
there's one more that we don't talk
about very often you know what it's
called fawn fawn
it's when you nuzzle up next to the
person and sometimes this is um you can
sexually nuzzle up to somebody i can
placate them
or which is a common trauma response
somebody abuses you and so what do you
do you get closer because it's safer
when i'm in here closer or you nuzzle up
relationally and you make peace you
concede your own body your own safety so
that the illusion of connection can
remain
and your body's keeping the score
and what i want for you is
i want you to go home and go to sleep
i want you to hand your daughter off to
somebody that you trust and feel full of
joy that that person gets to enjoy the
beauty of your daughter not terror
i want you to be able to go on a date
with your husband and leave your
daughter with somebody and be able to
breathe and
with when you're out with your
with when you're out i want you to be
able to breathe
right
yeah i always wonder
if one day my daughter sees her as a
trusted adult and she tells her
something that needs to be reported or
needs to be told to me
will she has she learned her lesson
who
my mom
like will can she be a trusted adult to
my daughter
you've got to let that fantasy go sister
she's she showed you what she's what
she's made of
and i'm sorry for that because you
deserved better than that
i can get choked up on your behalf you
deserve better
i got a little girl too
i got a six-year-old
you deserve better than that
yeah i know i'm sorry
the great thing you can do now is make
sure your daughter doesn't have that
you can make sure your daughter knows
she is anchored in
right
yeah absolutely and that starts with you
getting the healing that you need
probably your partner's gonna need to
join you on some of this too because
there's gonna be some
there's gonna be some uh
relational dynamics that will shift and
will be hard and
you got to stop trying to hold this
thing together because it's imaginary
and it's painful and it's duct taped and
the string is really starting to to fray
around the edges right
yes it is yeah
and i'm the only one holding it together
that's right and it's not your job
it's your mom's job
it's that piece of crap guy who abused
you's job
not the little girl
and the way this will be told the story
that will be told
will roll all the way back to that six
or seven year old little girl
that this was your fault
and savannah hear me say this this is
not your fault
thank you that's
very nice to hear
no no it's not very nice it's true
okay very nice to hear is your lawn
looks nice i like what you did with the
mulch in the garden
that's that's not it's it's i'm telling
you
this one's not on you
the the healing is it's your steps to
take
here's the thing today today
open up your phone book and call a
counselor call better help if you need
to and you can we've got links there
that we can hook you up
call somebody today okay i think this
one needs to be in person if if if i i
need to call somebody you can go meet
with in person pay what you got to pay
move some budget money around make this
thing happen
because you're worth it and start to
tell the story okay
and
work with your counselor on telling the
14 year old it makes me feel a little
bit better that all the visits are
supervised
um
and if she's got that level of
protection right now that she's not just
being fed a predator to a predator right
now that makes me feel a little bit
better okay right um
not a whole lot but a little bit work
through that
with your counselor okay and you're
looking at about a year probably okay
it's not quick okay
yes you're looking about a year okay
you're gonna have to learn how to do
life differently because you have been
ready to fight or run
for your whole life you don't even know
what piece feels like sister
this it's a common theme in
pretty much every uncomfortable scenario
in my life is i go i revert back to
feeling
that same feeling of um kind of just run
and hide yes
because the one person that was supposed
to have your back didn't
and then you went to the other
for sure one person that's gonna have
your back and she didn't
and that little six-year-old girl knew
at that moment you are on your own
you can't sleep deeply you can't get
super connected relationally you are on
your own you're attending to the fire
and
making clothes and making sure that we
don't get attacked
and nobody can handle that no physical
body body can handle that
and so when i say i'm sorry you've been
carrying this so much i'm sorry you've
been carrying it so much
this is professional help level stuff
and it's going to be a process you have
to re-learn how to live and you have to
change the oil while the car's still
driving right because you got a little
one right
and you're worth every single step of
the way
thank you so so much for being brave
call us back on the way i'm walking with
you through this whole thing call me
anytime